probable du président ukrainien à
Washington il y est attendu ce mercredi
d'après plusieurs médias américains vous
ne dit mirzelinsky doit s'adresser au
Congrès il s'agirait de son premier
déplacement international depuis le
début de l'invasion russe les précisions
de notre correspondant à Washington
Mathieu
vous imaginez son difficulté le secret
qui entoure cette visite aussi
exceptionnelle que surprise vous l'avez
dit volody mirzelinski est le président
d'un pays en guerre et en guerre contre
la Russie il est donc relativement
logique que sa première sortie du crâne
depuis le 24 février dernier vous l'avez
rappelé date du début de l'offensive
russe à l'est de son pays soit réservé à
son principal soutien les États-Unis
d'Amérique le président Joe Biden et
l'institution sans qui rien n'est
possible le Congrès des États-Unis cette
institution qui décide de l'aide
américaine accordée à l'Ukraine très
très peu de choses filtres sur la forme
que va revêtir cette visite
exceptionnelle évidemment et on l'a dit
on comprend aisément pourquoi Nancy
Pelosi cependant qui reste pour le
moment la patronne de la chambre de
représentants à cependant exigé la
présence de l'ensemble des
parlementaires américains pour entendre
le message que cette fois volody
mirzelinski formulera en face à face et
non plus en visio-conférence comme cela
a déjà été le il ne faut pas s'attendre
concrètement à de grandes annonces
cependant le soutien de l'Amérique est
déjà total aucun doute ne plane sur ce
sujet et surtout pas depuis les
résultats des élections de mi-mandat qui
certes donnent la majorité aux
républicains la chambre basse mais pas
au Sénat on s'attend à ce que le
président
ukrainien fasse l'état des lieux de la
guerre en cours une guerre concrètement
inimaginable il y a encore un an et au
cours de laquelle le peuple ukrainien
l'armée ukrainienne et leur président
ont littéralement sidéré le monde il
faut le dire par leur capacité à
résister à celle qui passait encore il y
a quelques mois pour l'une des plus
puissantes armées du monde j'ai nommé
l'armée russe les parlementaires qui
suivent de loin le conflit en Ukraine à
prendront de la bouche même d'un
président combattant qu’après avoir
repoussé les armées de Moscou et
reconquille une part significative du
territoire ukrainien le conflit sans
Lise inexorablement avec l'hiver dans
une guerre de position tout à fait
sordide qui voit
jamais ukrainienne et la population
bombardée en permanence par une armée
russe qui se réorganise à la faveur de
l'hiver et donc si volodimeki n'avait
qu'une seule chose à demander à formuler
devant ce Congrès des États-Unis c'est
évidemment le soutien le maintien de ce
soutien vital offert jusqu'à présent par
l'Amérique et ce dans la perspective de
la reprise des offensives du printemps
car c'est bien ce que redoute le
président
ukrainien le rendez-vous du dégel quand
les armées de Moscou auront capitalisé
sur les erreurs du dernier semestre
étoffer leurs effectifs recomplétez leur
soutes à munition pour reprendre le
combat de plus belle et laver il faut
lire les humiliations des derniers mois
même si le gouvernement
ukrainien ne communique que très peu sur
les pertes la seule certitude au
Pentagone est en entourage de Joe Biden
c'est qu'elles sont considérables pour
les ukrainiens et qu'à la différence des
Russes la ressource humaine militaire
ukrainienne n'est pas inépuisable c'est
pour cette raison que vaut le dîner ne
peut pas se passer les Américains et des
armes technologiquement supérieures qui
lui sont offertes depuis 10 mois
maintenant cette rencontre avec le
Congrès des États-Unis avec le président
Joe Biden Nag donc qu'un seul objectif
sanctuariser cette aide vitale pour
l'Ukraine une aide sans laquelle les
chars de Vladimir Poutine manœuvreront
sur la place principale de Kiev au
printemps prochain